російська церква в Україні має бути
заборонена це питання нашої національної
безпеки це найбільша громадська
організація яка напряму
підпорядковується гундяєву і Кремлю яка
зомбує українських людей яка виводить
мільйони українців на мітинги проти
Української держави і наших цінностей
Разом з тим ми маємо усвідомлювати що
всі ці люди більшість з них на відміну
від їхнього кліру не винні і наша
відповідальність допомогти цим людям
наша відповідальність проявити не волю
суддів а волю Української держави яка
має їм сказати порвіть зв'язки з Москвою
порвіть зв'язки з гундяєвим ніхто не
забороняє вам ходити в ваші церкви і
молитися Богу молитися тому кому ви
хочете ми демократична країна ми країна
яка діє на основі конвенції захисту прав
людини яку ми підписали і ратифікували
ми країна яка діє на основі рішень
Європейського Суду з прав людини і ця
конвенція і ці ріше шення прямо кажуть
що обов'язок держави берегти свою
національну безпеку російські попи яких
викриває СБУ і ми їм за це вдячні і СБУ
Як ви знаєте ініціювала теж ще один
закон про заборону діяльності цих попів
Україні зберігають зброю закликають до
проти Української влади боряться проти
Української церкви чому ми не виносимо в
зал ці закони що забороняє нам виконати
конвенцію захисту прав людини і
захистити національну безпеку під час
війни ці люди привели війну в Україну
через цих людей гинуть зараз українські
солдати Вони беруть зброю і в них
стріляють закликаю вас пане голово і
всіх колеги винести в зал всі закони
протидіяльності російської церкви в
Україну всім прийти на голосування
проголосувати і підтримати всі закони не
робити імітацію а заборонити нарешті цю
ракову пухлину в нашому суспільстві
дякую Слава Україні Героям
слава